انتقاده الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
علنا في روسيا يعتبر حدثا نادرا وتحديدا
اذا كان من مؤيد وفي حال ثبتت ادانتهم
بتهمه اهانه الدوله الروسيه او جيشها او
اهانه بوتين نفسه يواجهون غرامات وحتى
عقوبه السجن وفق دستور البلاد هذا القانون
تصدر المشهد بعد تسريب مكالمات لاثنين من
ابرز الشخصيات الداعمه لبوتين تصفه باوصاف
مشينه المكالمه المزعومه بلغت مدتها 35
دقيقه سربتها صحيفه ديلي ميل البريطانيه
وتناقلتها وسائل اعلام اوكرانيه وفي
المقطع الصوتي يمكن سماع صوت
للسناتور الروسيه السابق فرهاد احمدوف
والمنتج الموسيقي البارز يوسف بريكوزين
ينتقدان بوتين بقسوه وتحدث المنتج
الموسيقي عن الخسائر الروسيه في الحرب
الاوكرانيه
هو انه على بوتين سحب قواته من اوكرانيا
والاستسلام قائلا بان بوتين اقحم نفسه في
الامر ليرد عليه احمد وفق قائلا انه للاسف
سيمر وقت طويل قبل ان يقرر بوتين سحب
الجيوش من اوكرانيا مضيفا بان الحكومه
الروسيه
دمرتهم ودمرت الاطفال ومستقبل البلاد
ومصير كل الشعب الروسي ومنذ تسريب
المكالمه مشاهدينا حللت العديد من المنافذ
الاوكرانيه والروسيه المستقله تسجيل
الصوتي ووجدوا انه يعود الى الرابع
والعشرين من يناير الماضي بدوره ادعى
بان التسجيل مزيف والى ان الانترنت تحول
الى مكب نفايات كبير يمكن استخدامه لتشويه
سمعه الناس واكد انه يكن الاحترام الكبير
لبوتين وانه رغم خوفه من العواقب لن يفر
من موسكو لكن بالمقابل
احمدوف لم يعلق على التسريب فلنتابع
القرانيه